une vingtaine de personnes se sont
rassemblées samedi face à la mairie de
trappes pour se souvenir des victimes de
l'algérie on estime le coût humain de ce
conflit à 30000 morts dans l'armée
française et entre 300 mille quatre cent
mille victimes côté algérien attrape
nous avons davantage d'avoir été suivi
par par la mairie et le conseil
municipal depuis le début et on a
toujours commémorer le 19 mars la fin de
la guerre d'algérie
d'ailleurs on a une stèle ici pour le
maire de la ville guy malandain lui même
ancien combattant la cérémonie a une
résonance particulière à titre personnel
c'est une époque que j'ai connu mettez
vingt vingt neuf mois en algérie comme
tous les jeunes gens de l'époque
l'annoncent que c'était fini on pouvait
revenir à la maison il y avait eu il y
avait plus de risques nous le
commémorons chaque année avec beaucoup
de beaucoup d'émotion récemment les
années coloniales ont refait surface
dans l'actualité
plusieurs candidats à la prochaine
élection présidentielle ont exprimé des
points de vue divergent quant à la
qualification de cette période
le maire de trappes a de son côté
demandé plus de fraternité entre les
peuples
qu'est ce qui est important c'est que
les peuples se parlent s'expliquent
essaie de se comprendre et bâtissent
ensemble quelque chose de positif
l'algérie fait partie des derniers pays
de l'ancien empire colonial français à
avoir recouvré son indépendance